in this talk i'm going to talk about
three ros concepts and i will try to
explain them using examples from game
development with that said let's get
started
all right so let's take a game like
sogoban uh if you're not familiar with
this uh it's basically a 2d map very
simple uh you have a player you can move
the player with the arrow keys and you
have boxes that you need to push onto
the right places uh so you see here we
have a couple of boxes one of them is
red the other one is blue and we have to
push the red one onto the red spot like
this little guy is doing right now
all right so let's try to think how we
would model a game like sokoban using
rust concepts
so first we might choose to model the
color of the boxes and the spots as an
enum so you see there we have a box
color enum uh with two variants red and
blue uh we could of course have have
more in the future but that's just for
now um
next up we might choose to model the
player as a as a struct uh for now it
doesn't have any state the player
doesn't need to know that much
it's all about the spots and the boxes
in this game so
next up we have the box uh very simple
structure you see it has the uh just the
color is a member variable and the same
with the spots
all right let's think how
how we might choose to represent the map
itself so remember this is a 2d tile map
um
we'll probably want to store this in
some data structure
maybe a 2d array that part is not too
important so i'm kind of omitting it in
in this example but um
[Music]
we probably want to have a structure
that looks like this and we want to have
these two functions so the first one is
for getting a box in a particular place
in in the map so you see we are
receiving two arguments uh the x and y
positions uh these two are u8 uh it's
just unsigned eight bit integers uh
because we don't expect that
the map to be that big so um
eight bits should be more than enough
the other thing that you will notice is
that this api returns an option of a
game box so
this api is really supposed to give us
um
the box at the position if there is one
or nothing if there is no box at the
position and the same with the spot
and you might be wondering um
about options like why we chose to use
the the option type and really um
what what options are and why they are
so common in in rust so let's talk a bit
about options so
um as i mentioned so far options are
basically you either have something with
a value or you have nothing so you can
see on the left hand side um i just took
the the definition of the enum uh for
options straight from the standard
library so it's a new enum it has two
variants some with a t or none uh which
basically as i said means you can either
have something and you'll get the actual
value inside that or you could have
nothing um
options are very common in ros code um
i haven't encountered them that much in
other languages um
but they do exist as a concept and the
concept that you might be familiar with
from other languages is null options
really are a typesafe way of dealing
with nullability of the having something
versus having nothing so while in a
different language you might pass a
pointer to something
and you would rely on checking if that
pointer is null or not before actually
using the the value if there is a value
in in rust you you will use options and
you will rely on the
type safety that the variants of option
give you um this has a bunch of
advantages mainly the fact that the
client code
needs to very explicitly handle both
cases both when you have something and
you have nothing and there's no
risk of really forgetting to check uh
you could of course still do the the
wrong thing uh rust will not prevent you
from doing that but it does give you an
extra layer of type safety
the other thing is that it really helps
us
express intent when we define our
function function definitions
so as you saw in in the previous example
we can really say well this api will
either give you a box or it will not and
that is a very very clear way of reading
uh apis and designing apis um
lastly on on the left hand side um you
can see the option uh option type has
also some functions attached to it i
just put a couple of them like is sum
and is none uh these functions will
basically
um
tell us if
it which which variant were uh in a very
explicit way so next let's think how we
might choose let's continue with our
game implementation and think how we
might choose to implement uh checking if
the game has been won or not so what we
want to do is we want to really
check if all the boxes are on the right
spots so think that we will be iterating
through the map at every tile position
and we will
we want to have a function like this
which tells us is the box
on this position on already on the right
spot and we will pass the positions x y
which are just tile positions and this
will also take in the map because
obviously the map is aware of what it
really lives at every position
lastly this will return a boolean uh
because it will just tell us
it will return true if there is a box
and there is a spot
and they match correctly uh and false
for all other cases
all right so
first off this implementation uh is very
much like the first implementation that
you might write in in a ros program if
you are perhaps not very familiar with
either options or um
different ways of dealing with options
so
having said that let's get started so
we'll uh call mapgetbox which will give
us an option of a box and you see that
we're very explicitly assigning that to
a variable called box option uh we do
the same for the spot and then on line
five what we do is we actually use the
the functions that i mentioned before
about
checking if the option is something so
this again will will uh will only be
true if we have both a box and a spot in
this case if we do we move on and then
we actually unwrap the value that is
inside that option so unwrap is a
function that will basically
uh if we have something it will give us
that something and you can see the types
there are game box and game spot no more
option
but if we don't have anything unwrap
will actually panic and panic is an
unrecoverable error in rust so that is
interesting remember that for later
next up
now that we have the actual box and the
actual spot we can simply check the
colors and return the value of this
expression if the colors match
this will return true and everything is
fine if some of the options uh were none
either we had a box but there was no
spot or the other way around or we
didn't have anything maybe it was just a
piece of floor uh we will return false
so this is a pretty good implementation
however
it feels overly verbose and the other
thing that you might feel when you first
start working with options if you're
unfamiliar with them is it might feel
inconvenient it might feel almost like
you never have the right type that you
want and you have to keep unwrapping and
checking and constantly trying to
transform options into something a bit
more useful and that is a very natural
thing to do
the good news is there are other
constructs that ross provides that can
help you work with options better and
working with options is a very important
part of writing idiomatic rust and being
able to feel like you're using rust to
the fullest extent so
moving on let's think of what a
different implementation might look like
for the same function
so we could use something called e-flat
and again this is i have not seen this
in other languages much i think swift is
the only one that has it um
but it goes like this it's
we're gonna call mapgetbox with the x
and y position
uh and then we're going to say
if there is something in that box assign
it to a variable called the box
um this is basically a shorthand way of
writing what we wrote in the previous
option but you can see it's less verbose
we're basically just saying if we have
something in this box assign it to this
variable
return true from this condition
and move on so if we go to the next line
uh you'll see that we can do the same
for the spot and
finally now that we have both the box
and a spot
we will check the colors and we will uh
return that
similarly if
some of the options if if one of the
options was none
the iflat condition will actually return
false
so we will jump straight to line seven
cool
you might be thinking well this is
already less verbose which i completely
agree with um it's also more idiomatic
we're basically using a language
construct to deal with the options and
the if let will do the
checking of do we have something do we
have nothing and we'll basically assign
the something to a variable without us
having to check is none is some and and
do the unwrapping ourselves and this is
important because in the previous
example we could very easily forget to
check is some before we actually unwrap
the option and what that means is that
we could be unwrapping an option that is
actually none and that is a problem
because we will get a panic we will not
be able to recover from from that error
so
this code is slightly better from from
that point of view because it gives us a
bit of additional safety
the only inconvenience is the nesting
but i don't think that's such a big
problem especially when we only have two
options
um
next up let's think of a different way
that we might be able to write this code
so the other thing that we could use is
we could use a match construct uh match
again exists in other languages it's a
bit like a switch statement but a little
bit more
[Music]
elaborate you and more powerful you'll
be able to do a lot more things with the
match they will be able to do with
switch in other languages
we won't see their full power here
because this is a very simple example
but
you should know that so again we're
calling map get box we're calling map
get spot remember those return options
and
then we'll basically be able to say well
if the pattern that we've put in the
match
uh is some with a box and some with a
spot then do this
and we'll basically check the colors of
of the spot in the boxes
if
if not if
the pattern is anything else so that
could be we don't have a box or uh we
don't have a box or a spot then we'll
we'll go into line six and we'll
basically return false um as i mentioned
this is
much gives us the ability to do
more powerful things um we haven't seen
the full power of it because this is a
very simple example but i think
i think you get the point
arguably this is a little bit harder to
read we have some
slight complications in the syntax
because we're actually using a tuple to
be able to match on both sides otherwise
we would have to match on each option
individually which we could also do but
that would be a little bit longer uh
hopefully that made sense that was three
different concepts uh we talked about
options we talked about if led and we
talked about matches
hopefully that is enough to get you
interested in these concepts if if you
were not familiar with them before or if
you were uh hopefully it gives you the
appetite to dig a little bit deeper and
understand them a bit uh
deeper in terms of both how they are
implemented and how they help us write
more idiomatic rust um finally if this
sparked your interest in
making a gaming rust or getting started
with rust at all
i have a short online book that will
teach you how to make a game like
sogoban exactly what i showed you in in
the first gif um you'll basically be
able to build that at the end of this
book it's very short
i highly recommend you you try it out
and finally i put some links to my
social media profiles and
a link to the playground that includes
the code in this talk thank